>> Alright so, Stochastic Games are more general than
other models that we've talked about. And so, just to
make that case here's a way of making the Stochastic
Game settings more constrained. And, by making them more constrained,
actually turning them into other models that we've talked
about or could talk about. So, I wrote down three
different ways of constraining the Stochastic Game model. One says
that we're going to make the reward function for one player
the opposite of the reward function for the other. The next one says that the
transition function has the property that for any state and joint action and
next state. If that's going to be equal to the transition probability for state
joint action, next state, where we've changed
potentially the choice of action for player two.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So basically, player two doesn't matter
to the transitions or the rewards for player one, and the rewards
for player tow are always zero. So that's, that's again, you can specify
this as a Stochastic Game and then in the third case we
are saying that the number of states in the environment is exactly one.
>> So I claim that by doing these restrictions. We get out the
mark-off decision process model, a zero
sum statistic game model, and the repeated
game model that we've been talking about in
the context of, like, the folk theorem. So, what
I'd like you to do is write the letters, A, B, and C in the correct boxes.
>> Okay.
>> Go.